all right with record new cases in some
states we need to look at how the
current virus will impact the economy
over the summer we bring in Labor
Secretary Eugene Scalia mr. secretary
appreciate you taking the time on a
Saturday I remember sitting in this
chair on a Saturday back in March when
we were talking about 15 days of
shutting down businesses to quote slow
the spread we're now in late June almost
July and parts of Texas are shutting
down once again is it time to admit that
the economic effects of this and thus
the economic subsidies to help with
those are gonna have to go on for a lot
longer than we originally thought well I
think we did slow the spread and we did
flatten the curve which was the
objective of the measures that were
taken March April and and throw a lot of
country in May too
and we made tremendous progress both in
containing the virus and and and also in
building up our medical capacities so
that there are flare-ups
leyland we're ready to contend with them
we always knew the virus would still be
around we are reminded by what's going
on in some cities that it there are
still circumstances that cause a call
for care caution because the virus is
still here but we are reopening safely
and successfully throughout the country
putting millions to work millions people
are going back to work there's also
millions of people or hundreds of
thousands of people now who have gone
back to work who are not going to be
able to go back to work any more they're
gonna be employed by businesses they're
gonna have to shut down again I'm
thinking in Texas in Florida there's
talk of new shutdowns in Arizona stay at
home suggestions if not orders perhaps
coming in Los Angeles so is there gonna
need to be another round of PPP or the
$600 unemployment top-up insurance is
that gonna have to happen now well I
think there's a need above all Eiland
for people to continue to exercise
self-discipline and caution social
distancing masks in many circumstances
in terms of what might be done with
further legislation some of the programs
that you've mentioned or
going to expire at the end of July I
think there'll be discussions as that
approach is about whether additional
measures are needed the unemployment
benefit you mentioned was a really
important thing to be doing as we close
our economy that's $600 a week
additional federal benefit but I think
as we reopen the economy we're not going
to want to continue that particular
benefit but I think there's a good
discussion to be had about whether there
are measures we still will need you are
down in Texas earlier this week talking
to business leaders in Dallas here is
what noted Dallas businessman Mark Cuban
has to say about the situation there
take a listen when there is a problem
you step up and you address the issue
you provide comfort and you provide
details and you provide information to
the citizens so that we can make the
right decisions about our health and the
economy he hasn't done that he the Cuban
is referring to is the president I know
you're going to take issue with that but
talk to me about what these business
owners in Dallas were telling you I
can't imagine that they view shutting
down again as a viable option as the
governor is ordering there again is need
to be careful about the virus but
there's a lot of good stuff going on
right now in our economy and that was
what a lot of my discussion with the
business leaders was about we played out
a jobs report for May that was
stupendous we added two and a half
million jobs we're seeing consumer
spending rising record levels increases
same thing with new home construction so
there are a lot of really positive signs
and I heard a lot of optimism about
reopening and reopening safely and that
was that was a conversation in Texas
earlier this week so I think again this
week was also good for the American
workers the president signed a couple of
orders Monday signed that order to
suspend further immigrant workers so we
can get Americans all back to work and
then Friday signed a really important
order about the federal government not
requiring college degrees for jobs where
they're not needed you know interested
thirds of Americans don't have a college
degree and so this opens the federal
government to more workers so I think
there are lot of really good things
going on good for American workers
but the virus is still something we keep
an eye on obviously interesting what you
said about the college degrees we're
gonna have you back to talk about that
and what that might mean in those jobs
that'll make a difference for mr.
secretary appreciate you taking time on
a Saturday all the best sir okay my
pleasure Thank You Leland